it's the sequel everyone was waiting for
literally since the end credits of the
last one Avengers the age of Ultron
after one of the most hyped up and
biggest blockbusters of all time came
out everyone was waiting what the second
one was gonna be was gonna be bigger was
gonna be better was it gonna be funnier
in some respects yeah it is all those
things in other respects it's kind of
hard to keep the wow factor going after
such a groundbreaking last one does that
make it bad no does that make it better
than the first one
hey it's bad it's complicated okay let's
look at the set up the Avengers Assemble
once again in order to get Loki's
scepter huh they didn't meet up for all
those other times the world was about to
be destroyed it's a comic book don't
think about but Tony Stark's mind is
manipulated by another character called
Scarlet Witch who makes him see a
destroyed future that apparently he's
responsible for like an idiot he reads
it as I didn't do enough so he creates
this computer that's apparently gonna
create peace in our time oh come on he
didn't think that maybe this is what
would cause all those terrible things to
happen because you know the audience is
ten steps ahead of him on that but
whatever he creates this computer
program known as Ultron Ultron of course
was to create peace in his time but in
the way that he knows how by getting rid
of everyone oops forgot to overlook that
glitch
so now Ultron is trying to destroy the
world by making tons of different
versions of himself trying to raise a
giant city as a meteor and smash it into
the world and the Avengers have to
overcome their new mental problems as
well as new physical problems in order
to stop him so yeah pretty weak plot but
again the first film at a pretty weak
plot - and that didn't matter we just
wanted to see The Avengers get together
and fight and work off each other and
say those great one-liners and in
Avengers 2 we get all that plus more
actually there's a wonderful scene where
they've all been mentally ripped apart
and so they go to this cabin to try and
get away it's easily the best thing in
the film because we haven't seen
anything like that before it felt like
the Avengers were actually evolving as
characters and through a way that they
haven't really done yet so in some
respects it's exactly what we wanted but
in others
we want to see something we didn't know
we wanted like that cabin scene and
don't get me wrong I love that cabin
scene but why is there only one scene
like this in the movie and not more it's
kind of weird because the film does kind
of feel like it's on repeat here's all
these action scenes all these one-liners
and they're good they're well done
there's nothing wrong with them but
there's nothing really new about them
either the wow factor from this is kind
of gone because there aren't really any
new Avengers for them to interact off of
I mean okay there's the Scarlet Witch
and this vast guy and they create this
other one called the vision and at the
end they're indicating that there's even
more being added to the mix but all
these other characters had their own
movies half of these people are being
introduced in this film and the other
ones they were just kind of side
characters we're not exactly excited to
see them here now they're not bad but
they're no Thor Iron Man or Captain
America there's also a totally out of
nowhere romance between Black Widow and
the Hulk and it's good again
not bad but I'm not exactly gonna lose
sleep if I don't see them get together
but again it is evolving the characters
to a different place than when we
started I do feel I found out more about
these people after watching this film
than I did after watching the first
Avengers that's something that was
really missing in the last movie but
with everything else even if it's done
good the investment isn't quite as
strong because we can't have seen this
stuff before a bad guy who doesn't see
destroying the world as a bad thing and
he tries to make up some philosophical
bullshit about why it's not people being
hypnotized to do is will the whole world
about to be destroyed in one city and
again I hate talking this way because
it's done well in many respects it's
done better than the first film but it's
not evolving anything that much and
don't get me wrong the audience had a
fun time with us they were laughing they
were applauding they were gasping
they're doing all the things that
audience is supposed to do but when it
was all said and done there wasn't this
standing ovation like there was at the
first film because the first film gave
us a lot of what we never saw and really
wanted to see this gave us what we
thought we are going to see so it's hard
to say because
on the one hand it is kind of better
than the original we do learn more about
these people there is the wonderful
scene at the house the action is up too
there are more one-liners we do see a
lot more The Avengers together hell
there's literally one scene where
they're just hanging out at a party I
could just watch this the whole entire
time they're so interesting I guess the
real problem is it's not an experience
it's a sequel to an experience trying to
clearly be better and in some cases it
is but because we've already seen a lot
of this before it's not as much blowing
us away but it's still a lot of fun I
definitely recommend it doesn't have
stuff that doesn't make sense are there
elements that are clearly filler for
other movies sure but so did the first
one I don't think this is the
groundbreaking sequel they were hoping
for but at the same time we didn't get a
bad film by any means I think if they
did want to blow us away they would
include a lot more like why are the
guardians of the galaxy in there why
wasn't there a Spider Man cameo you just
got him now don't get me wrong if these
are all tie-ins that maybe I don't
understand I mean the fact that any of
this is happening in Hollywood is pretty
amazing so maybe they couldn't pull it
off but that's the reason people weren't
as blown away they wanted a lot more and
instead they got a little more in many
respects I do like this more than the
first one hell I probably prefer
watching this one to the first one but
it's not the groundbreaking follow-up
that I think audiences as well as the
studio was hoping for but hell with what
it is and concentrate on what it is a
lot of fun and really enjoyable if you
don't go in overhyped and just want to
see The Avengers being The Avengers this
is definitely a fun one to check out
assemble your team of friends and take a
look
you